so it's looking like credit Suites which
is a very large International Bank is on
the verge of collapsing this was already
predicted the bond market apparently is
is doing very very poorly and we've
we've talked about that in the past week
so uh as we're talking about this right
before the show starts Phil's like a Tim
First Republic Bank is trying to sell
now to another SF bank so this is going
to be the fifth bank we've got
silvergate was the first most people
didn't know or didn't care because it
wasn't that big but silvergate collapses
then what happened was because of that
Silicon Valley Bank brought the
statement about raising money and it
caused a panic everybody said is this
going to be like silvergate I don't want
to lose my money so they do a there's a
run in the bank Silicon Valley bank then
falls apart then Signature Bank falls
apart some people are trying to claim
that that bank was better but I don't
know all I know is that's three banks
that fell and now we have credit Suites
in the First Republic on the chopping
block so I don't know